Netflix has been ramping up its programming
slate in a big way in recent years, for better
and for worse.
There have been hit series that make it a
must-subscribe like Orange Is the New Black
and Stranger Things, but there have also been
a lot of projects that were severely over-hyped.
No entertainment giant is perfect, and with
that in mind, here's a look at some Netflix
originals that didn't live up to the hype.
Marco Polo
Marco Polo was hyped by Netflix as, quote,
"a timeless tale of power, adventure, betrayal
and lust that combines deft storytelling and
cinematic ambition."
Despite all that lofty language, however,
the series was a bonafide flop.
Sure, the show did earn some points for boasting
a culturally appropriate cast, and the company's
CEO lauded its popularity and called it a
"massive success,” though the 24% Rotten
Tomatoes score for the show's first season
suggests critics thought otherwise.
After two seasons, Netflix couldn't continue
funding the series and cancelled it, with
a reported $200 million loss to show for all
their efforts.
"Why do we need more?
I will tell you: because that is what comes
next."
Sense8
When the Wachowskis set out to make their
first small-screen series, their names alone
were enough to draw some enthusiastic interest
in the sci-fi show.
It certainly didn't hurt that Sense8 was met
with mostly positive reviews and was recognized
by the GLAAD Media Awards for its inclusion
of LGBTQ characters.
After two seasons, however, Netflix decided
to pull the plug on the series.
The show simply didn't attract enough of a
following to justify its cost of about $9
million an episode.
Following a roaring audience reaction to the
show's cancellation, Netflix did decide to
bring it back for a single two-hour finale
episode to offer closure.
The Get Down
This '70s-set musical-drama cost a whopping
$120 million to make, making it Netflix's
priciest series up to that point.
The streaming service also pulled out all
the stops to promote The Get Down, including
using graffiti art in big cities.
The investment appeared sound, and favorable
reviews certainly seemed to echo that.
However, the show's viewership didn't quite
measure up to expectations, with just over
three million pairs of eyes tuning in during
the first month of its run.
The show's failure to match the ratings of
far less expensive original series meant it
was predictably canned after a single two-part
season.
"You made it this far.
Just keep loving me and I promise it's gonna
all be alright."
Marvel's Iron Fist
Netflix had been on a roll with its Marvel
adaptations, but Iron Fist was met with stunning
disfavor, despite being heavily binged upon
release after a bevy of pre-release hype comparing
the series to its well-liked predecessors.
Some critics declared the inaugural season
a directionless snoozefest, while others took
umbrage with the appeal of the title hero
himself.
It didn't help that the show was also beset
with allegations of cultural appropriation.
Iron Fist's critical whomping didn't spark
a downward trend for the streaming service's
Marvel shows to come, but season one showrunner
Scott Buck was still replaced for the eventual
second season.
"Let’s go, you don’t belong here."
"I’m Danny Rand!"
Disjointed
It isn't just punnery to say that Netflix
had high hopes for Disjointed.
The pot-centric series featured Kathy Bates
as a cannabis shop owner and was spearheaded
by TV sitcom giant Chuck Lorre.
In other words, it was a stoner show with
solid talent in front of and behind the cameras.
What could possibly go wrong?
Well, despite some stylish marketing efforts
that included branded marijuana strains being
doled out at a pop-up dispensary, the series
simply failed to resonate with its intended
audience.
Critics found it to be plagued by obvious
jokes and a scattered plot that unfortunately
made good on the series' name, and the show
ended up being the worst-reviewed series of
the summer.
After a two-part season, the show was unceremoniously
snuffed out by Netflix.
"I am cool, because I don't take pot.
Pot is lame."
(crowd gasps)
Bright
This late 2017 sci-fi/fantasy movie was the
focus of a massive bidding war that resulted
in Netflix forking over $90 million for the
rights.
Bright featured Will Smith and Joel Edgerton
as cross-species buddy cop leads, specifically,
a human and an orc, both serving as an extended
metaphor for real-life racial tensions.
Despite an aggressive front-page promotional
push by Netflix, the reviews for the film
were an absolute bloodbath.
Even so, Netflix wasn't deterred by the bad
buzz and decided to greenlight a sequel.
"Now you keep doing all your gangster stuff.
I'm just trying to sell my house."
The Cloverfield Paradox
With the third installment in J.J. Abrams'
loosely connected series of Cloverfield films,
it was the method of delivery that felt like
a big power play: Netflix dropped the film's
trailer during the 2018 Super Bowl and revealed
that it'd be available for streaming just
after the game was over.
Thanks to the unexpected success of the first
sequel, 10 Cloverfield Lane, and the depth
of talent in Paradox’s cast, the film was
watched by five million people during its
first week online.
Despite that savvy marketing, though, the
film was absolutely eviscerated by critics,
who were even more disappointed in the film
after its major marketing splash.
(basically everyone's thoughts on the Cloverfield
series after this movie)
Mute
Duncan Jones waited a long time to make Mute,
the so-called "spiritual sequel" to his stunning
2009 sci-fi film Moon.
When Netflix finally helped usher the 16-years-in-the-making
movie into reality, Jones fans were definitely
paying attention.
Perhaps Jones should've let the film percolate
a few more years, however, because the final
product was lackluster, to put it kindly.
After all that build-up, what resulted was
an ultimately lifeless, disorganized, and
derivative film that didn't come anywhere
near living up to the expectations set by
its creator.
“It’s hard to be this good looking.
Big responsibility."
"Oh, yeah, that’s it.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!